This video is brought to you by Skillshare.
Internet people. Jared,
here it's been years since DC unveiled their expanded cinematic universe,
but unfortunately these days we can't think of Batman or Superman without
getting a little bit sad or very, very sad. Yeah.
Darkness.
So today we're going to face that sadness together and take a look at the big
question to end all big questions. What the hell went wrong with the DCEU?
Sure you can point to standalone successes.
People seem to like Aquaman wonder woman was pretty good, but unlike Marvel,
which managed to make over 20 movies with only a few.
Thinkers DCS.
And the missions seem to have crashed and burned.
How could such a sure thing turn out so disappointing the way we see it,
the problems can be traced back to two comics from 1986 and the mismanaged
influence they've had on superhero culture at large,
allow us to explain welcome to this wisecrack edition on the DCU,
what went wrong. And of course weather's a head for all the films in the DCU,
as well as slight spoilers for some excellent comics. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week.
Sponsors Skillshare Skillshare is an online learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and curious people with skill share.
You can explore new skills and learn more about your passions all from the
comfort of your own home. Right now, the world can seem very hectic,
but channeling your energy into doing something productive,
like learning a new skill can be a great way to relieve stress.
One class I recommend is everyday minimalism find common creativity in simple
living by Erin Boyle.
It's the perfect class to take in these times when everyone is trying to live
simply cheaply and find a sense of calm while being productive.
Aaron will teach you how to navigate stressful situations and how to make the
best with less. Not more.
Each Skillshare class comes with a discussion board and resources for you to
complete projects in tandem with the class.
It feels great to focus on something that isn't the news and stay connected with
the community of people who will provide support and encouragement.
A premium annual membership is less than $10 a month.
And right now the first 1000 wise crack fans to click the link in the
description can get a two month free trial. And now back to the show,
let's dive in. Now, of course, the DCU isn't over per se,
parts of it are even getting rebooted with definite articles,
such as these suicide squad.
And I highly anticipated the Batman still at a time when superhero franchises
are the biggest movies in the world, characters like cyborg flash,
and most egregiously Superman have seemingly disappeared to be fair.
It's not for lack of trying,
but there were fundamental issues with their plans from the very beginning to
make sense of those issues.
We first need to understand Superman and Batman and what they represent.
Two different versions of pure wish fulfillment,
not only in terms of putting on a Cape and fighting crime,
which would be awesome,
but in terms of the way they make us think about human potential Superman and
all his God-like power reflects what we wish we could be. He's by definition,
more than human. He is the fantasy of being freed from our physical limitations.
Batman on the other hand made himself who he is through drive will
persistence and a sizeable inheritance.
He pushed himself to the absolute extremes of human capability. In other words,
he's what we know we could be if we applied ourselves and maybe how to Butler
heroes also differ greatly in their psychology. Batman is irrevocably flawed,
no matter how hard he tries or how many billions he punches never get over the
tragic death of his parents.
And that's led him on a personal crusade against crime.
He is constantly engaged in the struggle too,
do the right thing because essentially there's not much separating him from the
villains he faces.
The key way that he does distinguish himself is in one clear unbreakable rule.
He will not kill lest. He become like the mugger who murdered his parents,
Superman for all his unearthly power is a rural farm boy at heart.
He isn't driven by trauma.
He simply believes that he has a moral and ethical duty to use his power to
help. He was raised to know about lying that you shouldn't harm other people.
And that honest work is more than good enough.
He doesn't generally involve himself in geopolitics or governmental policy
because he doesn't see it as his place.
He never uses more force than is necessary at his core.
He embodies everything good noble about the human spirit through this.
He reinforces faith in our values and provides hope.
At least these are your stakes, Batman and Superman.
Different artists have imagined Superman as a communist or Batman as a vampire,
but the way our two favorite superheroes I manifested in the DCEU as helmed by
Zach Snyder can directly trace their influence back to two specific works that
take a unique approach to heroics Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons Watchman and Frank
Miller's. The dark Knight returns.
Both of these comics were revolutionary when they debuted in 1986 because they
subverted and deconstructed so many superhero tropes by placing them within a
real world context,
both Watchman and the dark Knight returns pick apart the kind of society that
would necessitate superheroes and the kind of people that would be drawn toward
the superhero life.
They critique the very concepts of super heroics and vigilantism as well as the
effects that they would have on the world. Watchman took a wide view of the,
as a whole using newly created characters to represent the archetypes present in
superhero fiction, the comedian,
a stand in for flag wearing patriotic heroes like captain America,
gleefully quell, social unrest,
and commits atrocities in Vietnam can tend to be a tool for the government.
The all-powerful Dr. Manhattan mirrors,
all the unimaginably powerful heroes like Superman at captain Adam or silver
surfer,
but Manhattan's ultimate power leads to an increasing disconnect from the human
condition,
thereby questioning the fundamental humanity of this type of super being,
which tacitly leads us to consider what connects characters like Superman to
people like us and the kind of cold logic and greater good mentality that
characters like Batman so often fall into also comes into question with
Ozymandias is squid based master plan to unite the world under a common enemy by
killing. This brings the very notion of heroism itself into question,
pushing us to examine our own moral concepts of justice and good gadget,
loving detectives, obsessive crusaders, the leg, see hero,
all of these archetypes and more are expertly folded into a handful of
characters. However,
as we've seen more still treats them as real people with complex psychology.
None of them are truly good or truly bad.
Whereas Watchman looks at the entire genre.
The dark Knight returns hones in on a single figure. Batman,
it imagines a much older caped Crusader who has aged in real time issuing the
then unchallenged convention of [inaudible] comic book heroes.
We see the Batman Robin dynamic in a new light too,
with Batman characterizing the series of Robins that have as soldiers in this
telling the death of the second Robin,
Jason Todd was the biggest factor in Batman's decision to retire.
But when he fails to quell his crime fighting urges and dawns the Cape in
collagen,
he is more than willing to take another impressionable child under his wing.
This directly addresses the inherent irresponsibility of Batman in regards to
enlisting children and teenagers into his hyper violent war on crime Miller.
Also reappraisals the mythic perpetual struggle between Batman and the Jews.
Here are the joker has been pretty much comatose since Batman retired,
confined to Arkham and seemingly compliant.
But after man returns to Gotham the joker to resurfaces to continue their feud
Miller paints their conflict as an effect of Batman's presence,
suggesting that maybe it was Batman himself who caused crime to evolve into
super crime and the stakes to be irreversibly raised in Gotham city Miller also
features Superman as a naive ignorant yes, man,
for the government who wages a climactic battle against Batman,
essentially because the president said so overall Watchman and the dark Knight
returns broke new ground in the development of superheroes and were heralded for
their sofa were critiques of the genre.
But as revolutionary as they were both books come to somewhat pessimistic
conclusions about superheroes. Let's simply they're grim,
grimy and hella cynical.
They both feature the governmental regulation and prohibition of superheroes.
For example,
suggesting that the natural response to super beings would be military
application and they both paint heroes as psychologically compromised,
driven by neuroses and disorders. Unfortunately,
the comics industry didn't really get this after the massive critical and
commercial success of Watchman in the dark Knight returns,
everyone tripped over themselves to mimic the grim and dark aesthetic of these
two revolutions. Mary works,
but their imitation was only surface level and led to what is known as the dark
age of comics. Suddenly everything,
everything had to be dark and gritty and superheroes turned into poles who
killed villains.
Indiscriminately optimism was seen to be cheesy replaced with baseless,
exed, blood Gore and rampant over sexualization was everywhere,
but seemingly just for the aesthetic,
without the nuance and complexity of Watchman and the dark Knight returns,
the stories were ultimately hollow.
Enter Zack Snyder before Snyder was becoming known as the comic book guy in
Hollywood,
mostly due to his faithful of Watchman and during the press for Watchman
Snyder, lauded to comics over all others, Watchman duh,
and the dark Knight returns even mentioning his desire to adapt the latter for
film.
And here's where we get into the real meat as to why the DCEU fell flat on its
face.
The same cynical deconstruction that worked for Watchman and the dark Knight
returns seem to inform every decision Snyder made when building the DCU,
he could only see the superheroes and the world.
They inhabit through a grimy pessimistic lens,
but just like the dark age of comics,
Snyder seemed preoccupied with the dark surface rather than the intellectual
core furthering this,
his overriding warship of those fabled deconstructive as comics caused a big
problems when he drew from other less gritty source material to highlight this,
let's look at man of steel.
The origin story for the granddaddy of all superheroes Snyder actually draws
from a lot of influences here,
predominantly the classic optimistic Superman comics birthright by Mark Wade and
all-star Superman by grant Morrison.
The movie wears these influences on its sleeve.
Things like Clark flying alongside a herd of zebra and the S crest on his
costume standing for hope.
So this symbol means the symbol of the house of elements out.
Are pulled straight from birthright, even lifts the speech,
almost word for word from all-star Superman.
You will give the people of earth an ideal to strive towards
they'll race behind you. They will stumble or fall,
but in time
they will join you in the sun down.
The standards nods to these inspirations are essentially lip service.
We get acknowledgements by the way of shared design imagery and dialogue.
On my world. It means hope.
The Snyder seemingly can't reconcile their hopeful,
uplifting themes with his own cynicism. We know this because whenever possible,
man of steel takes the dark and gritty option. We covered this in our,
what went wrong for man of steel,
but between the rampant collateral damage and Superman actively murdering Zada,
the climax man of steel doesn't look kindly upon the big blue boy scout.
The creative team has explained that the intention was to have him eventually
grow into the morally grounded Superman we know and love,
but here's the problem.
Snyder introduces the character already subverted his anx and general hand
wringing placing him closer to a reluctant hero instead of the Paragon of truth,
justice and hope. But Superman is arguably the archetypal superhero.
You can't introduce a definitive archetype and deconstruct that archetype
simultaneously. Otherwise you're not introducing Superman.
You're introducing big flying dude.
The prodo Superman that we see in man of steel is ultimately so far from the
Superman that we recognize that he's a different character entirely Snyder gave
us even more insight into this choice in an interview in which the journalist
stated that the so-called no wind scenario is the only way to test a heroes
rules and ethics. Snyder agreed adding that.
It's the only way to move forward with the hero because otherwise the hero
drowns in the mire of his own morality. According to this,
you can view the climax of man of steel as the ultimate moral, an ethical test,
except Superman fails in every conceivable way.
Literally the first metahuman Superman has to deal with,
causes him to lose all phones, focus, allowing metropolis to be leveled,
countless people to die. And Superman becomes a murderer. Snyder.
Superman doesn't even register that. He could do anything else other than snap,
some necks.
This is a textbook example of dark and gritty disguised as supposed clever
subversion.
It's worth stating that at this point Snyder's plan to essentially build up to a
true Superman was still viable. We'd only seen one movie after all,
which brings us to Batman,
the Superman and where the cracks really begin to show.
See Batman V Superman was supposed to be another Superman film,
a direct sequel to man of steel,
but then Snyder decided to add Batman in there and make Millers.
The dark Knight returns. The central influence Batman V.
Superman is notorious for being a dumpster fire of a movie. And again,
we've covered it in its own, what went wrong. But for this video,
let's look at Snyder's two main inspirations.
The dark Knight returns as mentioned, and the death of Superman,
which Snyder chooses to take from them and what he chooses to admit. Once again,
demonstrate his fascination with surface level gritty subversion.
The first time we see them together on the big screen,
we get a frankly psychotic Batman, killing goons,
branding people and straight up premeditating,
the cold blooded murder of Superman and Superman. Well,
he's just sort of there perhaps presumably internally struggling and taking
these surface level angst and violence from the dark Knight returns,
but ignoring the deeper themes. Snyder creates a contradiction and character.
Whereas the dark Knight returns asks us to consider the archetypical Batman's
relationship to violence or Robin Snyder simply wants us to consider how cool it
is that Batman brands, people or put another way.
The dark Knight returns is in conversation with and criticizes the established
Batman mythos Batman V Superman on the other hand is talking to itself and it's
mostly saying grit is good.
The same issues apply to Snyder's use of the death of Superman.
Ironically could have helped Snyder build up his wholesome version of the man of
steel released in the midst of the dark age of comics. The death of Superman.
See Superman died at the hands of doomsday, four separate heroes, super boy,
steal Eradicator and cyborg Superman,
try to fill the hole that his death has left a metropolis to varying degrees of
success.
But when a bigger threat in the form of Mongol aided by none other than cyborg,
Superman appears to wreak havoc.
Superman returns from the dead proving to be the only one who can stop them
and be worthy of the title of Superman. The medically,
the whole story revolves around the notion that a dark and gritty Superman isn't
Superman at all the methods of the four replacement Superman actually reflect
the edgy grim heroes of the nineties. However, the only thing Snyder,
this is Superman plus death rather than seeing how Superman's death could
fulfill Phil. His arc of redeeming him,
Snyder ignores everything else to once again,
hyper-focus on the surface fact that Superman done died by time justice league
rolled around the damage had already been done.
We pick up where Snyder left off Superman's dead Batman's guilt-ridden and
struggling with his violent tendencies and wonder woman's oddly detached from
everything. While we may never know the entirety of Snyder's plans.
What we do know,
paint a somewhat conflicted picture on the one hand Snyder's vision would have
revealed Martian Manhunter and green lantern completing the iconic justice legal
lineup facing off against dark side,
which makes it hard enough to pine for what could have been.
But on the other hand,
even more time would have been spent in the nightmare future,
but they decimated justice league fighting back against the brainwash fascist
Superman.
That part would have been inspired by Tom Taylor and Brian Buccellato injustice
comics,
a grim gritty and cynical deconstructive tale that asks what if Superman broke
bat based on Snyder's previous adaptations, it's not hard to extrapolate.
We suspect the same kind of surface level cynical interpretation would have come
into effect here too.
But ultimately we can't know for sure because Snyder didn't get to complete his
vision.
And we'll never really know if his controversial choices would have paid off
still.
The fact remains that we did get most of the story and most of us hated it so
much so that it killed the idea of an interconnected cinematic universe dead.
It's not all doom and gloom though.
DC and Warner brothers have stepped back from their sprawling plans of
connectivity,
handing the reins over to a creative team that are willing to embrace the
bright, playful and hopeful nature of the genre. Wonder woman Aquaman,
and Shizam have generated warmer reception from fans and critics alike and
indicate a less depressing future for DC films.
But what do you think wise crack did Snyder missed the point or are we being too
hard on the guy? Let us know what you're thinking. The comments,
thanks to our dope patrons for supporting the channel and our podcasts slam that
subscribe button and as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].